knows Michael knows hey everybody
international Man of Mystery Michael
Knowles here you know I love my martinis
stirred not shaken actually and I love
if I say anything about women it'll be a
little too sauce I love gambling in a
nice white dinner jacket at some Casino
somewhere in Monaco and in this game of
chance I want to take a look at the
current betting odds on the next James
Bond man I haven't heard of like half
these people or more than half these
people first up is Aaron Perry Taylor
Johnson how many names does this man
have he's an English actor best known
for his portrayal of the title character
in Kick Ass and its 2013 Sequel and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe character
Pietro maximoth in Avengers Age of
Ultron never heard of this guy never
seen him in my life he has an earring I
don't like that he's wearing what
appears to be a blouse I don't love that
I don't know anything about his acting I
haven't seen any movie he's ever been in
but
Eileen now
Eileen no okay you tell me what you
think next up James Norton last I heard
he was on Opie and Anthony radio and
then he just jumped up to become James
wait that's not Jim Norton okay so James
Jeffrey Ian Norton or the English all
blessed with four names he has an
English film television stage actor
known for roles in the television series
Happy Valley Grant Chester War and Peace
and Mick Mafia
um
no no he just doesn't look it
that guy is not James Bond just doesn't
have the face for it okay Tom Hardy I
have heard of Tom Hardy and I've heard
he could be a good James Bond I forget
what I saw him in I've seen him in a
movie or two though he studied at the
Drama Center London made his film debut
in Black Hawk Down he had supporting
roles in Star Trek Nemesis and rock and
rolla went on to store in Bronson
Warrior Lawless this means we're in luck
uh he could be good I could see that Tom
Hardy's very good actor Jack Loden Jack
Andrew Lowden is a Scottish actor the
Scots only get three names following a
four-year stage career his first major
International on-screen success was the
BBC series War and Peace oh he was also
in Dunkirk uh no a redhead is not going
to be James Bond I go to church I'm a
Christian you don't know me I mean I
guess if he's Scottish
there's something kind of cool about
that okay hold on I withdraw my
immediate rejection of that yeah okay
whatever maybe Henry Cavill is another
one with four names Henry William
dagnyish Cavill I know I've seen him in
something that I don't remember what
he's known for the Tudors Superman and
The Witcher and he played Sherlock
Holmes in the Netflix movie Inola homes
and it's 2022 sequel yeah I could see
him he looks like James Bond uh Ray J
jean-page John Page I don't know he is
an English actor he appeared in Waterloo
Road on BBC One roots on history and for
the people on the ABC before becoming
known for his role in the first season
of the Netflix period drama Bridgerton
uh
[Music]
all right I'll just
I assume you're watching this on Media
Matters at this point because James Bond
is not a black guy
okay I like black guys a lot I got
nothing against black guys some of my
best friends are black but James Bond is
not a black guy
he's a white British guy
so it's not going to work this guy could
be the greatest actor in the world I
don't know I've never seen his acting
but
no
I could try to keep an open mind but nah
I don't go quite so far as say August
Wilson who is one of the most important
black playwrights in American history
who says that colorblind casting can
never happen he hates the idea of color
blind casting thinks that black people
should only play Black rules written for
black people I don't go quite that far I
always think of Denzel Washington in
Macbeth that was just a great recent
performance where the race didn't really
matter but in this case it does James
Bond's a white guy okay this brings us
now to The Perennial floated character
or actor rather for James Bond Idris
Elba Idris elba's a terrific actor he
could play a lot of great roles but that
isn't the character he can't play
Michael Corleone Michael Corleone is an
Italian guy Oscar Isaac Oscar Isaac
Hernandez Estrada
okay again I'm gonna
a guy with the last name Estrada can't
play James Bond okay and he's an
American actor okay so that's a joke
this guy's obviously not going to play
James Bond
you don't even have an English accent
okay I'm looking at the guys here now so
I forget their names other than Idris
Elba anyway I'm just gonna go in order
left to right top to bot
oh like almost certainly no
No Maybe
probably not but maybe maybe no no I'm
gonna have to be Capital based on this
list says Ruby the strata could play the
villain yeah that's true a lot of people
calling for a transsexual I vote for the
Scottish guy bias because I'm Scottish
says Catherine my name Mr Davies is
James Bond okay Davies is getting a lot
of votes here Martin Lawrence as big
mama as James Bond would be great
if Cleopatra can be black so can James
Bond Fair Point a fair buoyant Cavill
and Tom Hardy those are the guys winning
up there all right place your bets
I'm Michael knows it's the Michael knows
you'll see you tomorrow
[Music]